hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
Brian stelter is still an unlikable
potato
first of all we have some sad news for
this show
Brian stelter is leaving CNN I know yeah
apparently he wants to spend more time
with his food
hi kid the pop and fresh king
I'm gonna miss him how much well this
much
and the Press was so quiet on CNN you
could hear stelter's stomach growling I
can't control myself just like Brian
stelter at Krispy Kreme like Brian
stelter trapped in a Frito-Lay Warehouse
they eat everything from the inside like
butter at Brian stelter's dinner table
it's spreading everywhere no hard
heartfelt birthday wishes from CNN's
chubby grubby Teletubby CNN's roly-poly
gossip goalie but anyone who thinks that
boobs are more common in women than in
men clearly have never seen Brian
stelter jogging that worked out about as
well as Brian stelter's personal trainer
but hey let's cut Brian some slack he's
got a lot on his plate right now
what the hell am I gonna do now